so if we took a not so great or sort of
a mediocre bland screenplay we put it on
the same table and disassembled it we
would see not enough conflict and then
we would see maybe and this is like sort
of a bad word but emotional manipulation
within the story because you're saying
that these audience the audience the
readers they want these clues they don't
want to be given information right
well there's as I say there's many more
ways of being sick than there are being
healthy so if we if we read a script
that doesn't quite work for us then
obviously the issues are manifold what
kinds of mistakes we make there's a with
my like with my students not that my
students are brilliant and they hardly
ever make mistakes but let's just say
there's that outlier that makes a
mistake once in a while there's a
tendency in no particular order the
things that I see and I see it in
feature films too that don't quite work
there's the tends to be a
misunderstanding of in the scheme that
I'm talking about what does it mean to
have the end of the second act you'll
see it there its drummed into a lot of
them that this is a low point or some
kind of all this lost moment or you know
everything's hopeless and everything has
to get really really bad and it's not
necessarily so it depends on what your
story actually is the end of the second
act is where the question is answered
but the third act is really it's
resolved but preferably in a in a way
that is turns the story into something
deeper its Milosz foreman said when I
studied with Mueller's Foreman at
Columbia days and he put it this way he
said in a in a standard classic feature
with drama the audience's got to usually
to possibility
you know the person gets it or they
don't so let's say it's hypothesis a or
hypothesis B we hope for hypothesis a we
are afraid it's going to be hypothesis B
but the audience isn't satisfied if the
third act is either A or B
it's got to be C it's got to be
something that transforms the way in
which we're aware of what the deeper
meaning to the story and that's what
really the function of the third act is
we we often feel like okay the main
character doesn't in the classic
formulation that I think most people go
by when they're trying to write a script
a character wants I'm going back to I
don't have sex on my mind but once the
girl that's just say oh that's easy
let's say all right a bank and they want
to make money let's say they want to get
their money back from someone who stole
it that that's let's say that's it and
they go all through the movie once you
know that you know they take this
various action to try to get that
objective then the idea would be at the
end of the second act it doesn't look
like they're ever gonna get it okay oh
it's impossible I all odds are against
them but in the third act they managed
to get it okay that's that's a classical
formulation but there's other ways of
seeing it that it can be very powerful
and and I try to encourage my students
to examine those when they're looking
when they're looking at a story when
they're coming up with it what happens
if they get it at the end of the second
act but isn't what they thought it was
or they paid a price on it or the price
was too big or they did it but in the
process damaged someone so deeply that
now they have to deal with the
consequences of what they did though
those are ways of really turning a story
and examining the theme and making it
powerful like examples from the book and
the analyses that I do are in Toy Story
it's about this guy who
wants to maintain his position at the
top that's what it's about
and the question is a he maintains it or
gets it back or B he he never gets it
back that's how it's presented but at
the end of the second act what happens
well it isn't a question of that anymore
he gives up and recognizes that there's
he becomes selfless selfless and and
then the two team up the question is an
answered a or b it becomes seen we're
going to accept whatever the outcome is
but we're gonna help each other so you
wind up with this up lit really
uplifting ending in and you also when
you do this when you open yourself up to
that possibility it you can actually
reverse the tension in a way the typical
feeling is I love this character let's
look at the tennis court I love that
character and they're in deep trouble
and I want them to win but there are
times when the character wants something
you don't want them to watch what you
don't want them to get and that tension
is perfectly valid and we we see like go
back to classic the apartment where the
main character wants to climb his way to
the top that's not what really weren't
for him what we want is for him to be a
true human being who's not degrading
himself constantly to get to the top we
want him to be a full human being who
gets true love that's what we want
that's not what he wants that's not what
he's pursuing through most of it so the
end of the second act he gets everything
he could possibly want and then I like
it and now we explore like the movie
from a different point of view
you take the premise and you flip it and
that's that's something that I have to
work with my students because there's an
automatic tendency to just go with the A
or B and an example of a movie that I
felt a movie that I've seen that I felt
could have used a rethinking of it was
the
probably going to forget the name again
oh the REM the revenant came out a few
years ago okay so it's a root of very
simple revenge story this guy left me
for dead and lied about it
and I'm gonna just get that guy so
what's the tension he's either gonna get
him or he isn't and along the way you
know we have these sub scenes they're
not all against that guy none of them
are they're all about overcoming the
elements and the bad guys and being
helped by somebody into winter weather
and the river that would have killed him
within 30 seconds but this is Hollywood
so it worked out okay and so it gets all
the way to the end now you're in a
position they manage the filmmakers
managed to put themself in a position
where it was gonna be predictable it's
either gonna be the final fight is
either gonna get the guy or he isn't
gonna get the guy and he's probably
gonna get the guy and so inevitably in
this kind of movie where they have
limited their options as storytellers
it's gonna come down to a fight and the
fight is gonna have a moment where the
bad guy almost kills them maybe there's
a knife but somehow the good guy finds
just enough at reserve of energy where I
came from we don't know but somehow
they're able to throw them off and then
get the upper hand and they die a
horrible horrible death in this case he
doesn't kill him but he does pretty much
the same thing too it was done to him
but look at that story I mean I think
what what are the other options if
you're that story comes to me and I'm
looking at it thinking well the main
character is a guy who wants revenge is
that even the most interesting character
this is what I would do with this to
turn this around what are these other
characters here well okay there's the
bad guy you could always see the bad
guys don't think they're the bad guy
they think they're doing it right
they're just living with the times we're
going with the flow okay so this guy
leaves him for dead why does he leave
him for dead well he thinks that he's
gonna be a drag on the group and they're
all gonna die that's not a bad thing is
it that's a difficult question
now they came
did the character is this evil guy but
there's another character there the
there's a army officer who's leading
them what if it's the men are his
responsibility and he almost knows for
certain if we keep this guy then all my
men can die now that's an interesting
problem and so he does something
questionable he leaves him for dead or
thinks he's dead and then he finds out
the guy's alive and that to me is a more
interesting dilemma and the third act
could be the confrontation between them
or it could be something more
interesting it's not just gonna be a or
b it's gonna be how do I redeem myself
how would I get this person to
understand I didn't do it what what are
the issues it becomes a lot richer of a
story and you can probably still get a
go a go in the river you know the frozen
river and you could probably still have
that stuff but you're not locked into
something that's just a or b so that's
that's what I see when you're talking
about a script it doesn't quite work a
lot of good things in it but but it kind
of left with okay well let's go home it
doesn't lead me away the thing in terms
of story development when I work with
students there is a this notion that
occurred to me it reminds me of a has
this old Zen saying so we can be a
little bit Zen here just shortly show up
at a time but there's a saying that to a
beginning student the rivers are rivers
and the mountains and mountains right
but to an intermediate student the
rivers are no longer rivers amounts are
no longer mountains to an advanced
student though guess what you know the
rivers are rivers again in the mountains
amounts well I I see this you can
probably google that and I'm sure you'll
find it under Zen sayings about
mountains but to a beginning
screenwriting student you want to write
a script just start writing a script
okay write the scenes okay I got this
okay I'm gonna start writing and if you
put a bunch of scenes together you'll
have a script you'll have a story
an intermediate student learns no no you
have to plan the story first you've got
to know what what is the story how do
you know what scenes you're gonna have
unless you have a the story that tells
you and I've run into this I've when I
read an unsolicited script very often I
start with a lot of notes which are
pertaining to the moments the scenes and
then I realize after few pages in wait a
minute I don't even know if the story
needs those scenes I gotta fight figure
out what the story is because then I'm
wasting my time writing detailed notes
on scenes that I should be thrown out
because you don't need them or they're
not optimal for the story so that's
that's the intermediate student but when
you get to the advanced level you
realize that again going back to
constructivist psychology characters
audiences don't actually see stories at
all they don't what do they see they see
scenes okay they see scenes and in the
process of watching the scenes they
construct a story in their minds I put
the scenes together
and they understand there's a story but
the story is not materially present ever
it's always just constructed in our
heads and therefore since all you see
are scenes when you have a premise the
way you want to develop it it's a way
that maximizes the amount of really cool
scenes in it that I see sometimes see
students well here's a story and I have
to stick with it
but the way you've developed a story
you're not allowing for any really
interesting scenes I've seen those
scenes I've seen the ones in revenue you
know I've seen in variations and I've
seen that fight before but maybe you
could turn the story in a way that yeah
that's gonna be a really cool scene and
how about that one you you don't you
realize if you withhold the information
here from the character now you've got a
scene that has a double meaning to it
there's a scene in a script that I
consulted on and did a rewrite on and
and there was the father is finds the
daughter with a lover he shouldn't she
shouldn't be with and it's like how
could you do that
it's like what father I hate you you
know it is exactly the kind of scene
you'd see oh and he
time anywhere but my but the way I redid
it was that the lovers are together and
and they see the father coming and the
daughter hides and the father sees the
guy and he's really in a tough mood he's
struggling with his career and he sit
down with the guy with the daughter
right there and he's talking about his
relationship with his daughter and how
he doesn't understand her and he wants a
you know everything is really rich now
yeah cuz we know that the daughter is
hiding there and and that's a really
cool scene let's do that
seeing let's put that scene in rather
than one that we've seen a million times
and it's all it come it can come down to
how you choose to develop it so the
scripts that don't quite work I've seen
that pattern with the third act I've
seen choices made in terms of developing
them that don't fit that don't maximize
the possibilities that are present there
there there's the question of which we
have not talked about of dialogue now
what dialogue is
you